- I think there's a lot of
voters out there who are,
who have reevaluated maybe
some of how they voted.
Some people just vote
one way or another.
Maybe their parents
were Republicans.
So they were
Democrats or whatever.
Now people are starting
to look, wait a minute.
Do I want to be with a party
if this guy's the leader,
do I want to be a part
of a party that says
I don't have a right to earn a
living unless I take boosters
every time Fauci tells me to?
Do I wanna be a part,
do I want to be a part of a
party that doesn't believe
we should have control over
our territory and our borders?
Like you see what's going
on in the Southern border.
And I think a lot of people
are saying you know what,
that's not for me.
So it gives us an
opportunity I think to build
a stronger movement here.
And I think the Southern Florida
is gonna be absolutely huge
to the future of this state.
(gentle music)
- I moved to this great
state six months ago okay.
And I gotta tell
you as I opened with
you guys have done it right.
And it's, it's you and it's
you and it's you and it's you.
And it's everyone in this room.
And it's that Florida man knew
something that the rest of us
had forgotten or
maybe we never knew.
And I promise you that I am
here to keep Florida Florida.
And I'm also here
to support this guy,
ladies and gentlemen Governor
Ron DeSantis everybody.
Governor Ron DeSantis.
♪ Florida ♪
♪ My governor is red,
white, and blue ♪
♪ Oh down in sweet Florida ♪
♪ He's shooting it straight
telling us the truth ♪
♪ Yeah that's right ♪
(cheering)
- Good evening Orlando.
And again welcome to
the state of Florida.
- Thank you.
- You know if you come
from California, we all,
we do have reservations
when people come,
but you're doing it right.
And so I really believe a lot
of the people that have come
in the last couple years,
I think they're making the
state more red, not less red so.
- Yes.
(cheering)
- I don't know if you heard
right at the beginning,
how many of you guys are new
Floridians last year or two?
(cheering)
- Wow.
- I mean look at that,
that is a beautiful thing.
I feel I can either ask you
questions or we could just let
people say nice things to
you for the next 40 minutes.
What do you think
we should do here?
- Well look, I think
it's your show.
I'm just here for the ride,
but we're excited to be here
and congratulations
on the book man.
- Thank you, thank you, alright.
(cheering)
Alright, so first off we have
to start with the obvious one.
Gay.
(laughter)
He didn't even flinch,
nothing, nothing.
You just, I thought that in
this state we can't say gay.
There's people outside,
they're freaking out.
They've got bullhorns, man.
What is, I mean, did
you choose this fight
or do you feel like they,
they just brought it to you
and you just punched back?
- No, yeah.
Look, I mean look,
I'm I'm punching back.
It was interesting when that
bill was going through the,
when the legislature's
in session, they're
there for 60 days
and there's a lot of
stuff that's going on.
I'm not following every
little committee hearing
or anything.
I mean I've got
dozens of priorities
and I've got folks working on.
So I'm out just doing my
job doing other things
and making announcements
like we do.
And the media
starts badgering me
with these slogans about gay.
And I'm thinking
to myself, okay,
this isn't my first rodeo,
I know what they're doing.
They create narratives
and then they try to run
with these narratives.
So I know they're lying.
I don't know how they're lying,
but I just know they are.
So I ask myself what
is going on with this?
Why are they doing this?
And then I see, and I'm like
you've gotta be kidding me.
Are they honestly going to
make this the hill to die on?
And so even though it was
not necessarily legislation
that I had authored initially,
I started fighting
back against them
'cause they were
just lying to people
and it's offensive
when they're lying.
And, and so we
start fighting back
and I would literally
have these reporters,
I'd say okay where does
it say that in the bill?
Okay, it doesn't say that in
the bill, what does it say?
Oh, so you know, and so it
was, it was, it was good.
We were fighting back.
And then you had this
situation where you had
the corporations, mostly Disney
deciding to get involved.
And I think people look at that.
They're like first of all,
I don't know why they
got involved in this.
It was a huge mistake for them.
They think they've lost
60 billion in market caps
since they got involved.
But what, what the
left is doing though,
it's honestly smart for them.
They know that if people knew
that if they were running
for election on gender
ideology for kindergarten
and first graders that would
not fly with the voters okay.
Parents just don't want
that for these young kids.
And a lot of the elderly
in Florida don't even know
what the hell you're
talking about.
So it's not, it's not good.
And they know they can't
win elections on that.
So I think what they, what
they try to do which is smart,
they say okay if we could
subcontract out are leftism
to a corporation,
pressure the corporation
to come on our side,
then maybe they can get these
elected officials to cave.
And you know what, it's
not a dumb strategy.
'Cause there have been a
lot of Republican governors
that have caved to
corporate pressure.
You've had Republican
governors veto bills
just to protect women's
athletics and women's sports
because some of the
businesses got upset.
So I understood why
they were doing it.
I thought it was a mistake
for Disney to get involved
and I told them you
shouldn't get involved.
It's not gonna work
out well for you.
So they kind of got involved.
- I don't know if you heard
what Donald Duck's been up to.
But.
(laughter)
- You know but the thing is is,
is you know they're
gonna go out.
And honestly I think
it's ridiculous when
these corporations
do all this stuff, but
you're free to do it.
But when they're lying
and they're accepting
these phony narratives.
Just think what happened
last year when Georgia
did their election
integrity law.
You had a massive hysteria by
corporate media, by the left,
by Twitter and all this stuff.
You had Delta Airlines,
you had Coca-Cola
demagogue the bill,
they equated it to Jim Crow.
You had Major League Baseball
move the all star game
out of Atlanta.
And so we've now had our
first election in Georgia
earlier or last month
under the new law.
Record voter turnout.
And so they were lying
about the Georgia bill.
Anyone who read it would know.
And so I think when
they're accepting
these false narratives,
especially if it's
about people in my state
that are in the
legislature or whatever,
we have a responsibility
to fight back.
But I think Disney took
it one step further
when they put out this
incredible statement
after they already did all
their virtue signaling.
After we signed the bill saying
this was somehow violation
of human rights and that
they would work to see
that parents' rights in
education were repealed
through the legislature.
And I'm just thinking
to myself, you know,
I took an oath to
support the laws
and constitution of the US
and the state of Florida.
I did not take an oath to
subcontract out my leadership
to a corporation based
in Burbank, California.
They don't run this state.
(cheering)
And so, but again they
are free to do that.
I think for a publicly
traded corporation,
I think it's stupid.
And so I think that you're
gonna have a situation.
Alright, butt out, nobody
wants to hear from you.
Nobody wants to hear
from you, get outta here.
(jeering)
- Got plenty of friends for
you across the street my man.
- So they get into,
they commit themselves
to this really ridiculous
course of action.
And they're free to do that.
It's not smart as
a publicly traded,
but you are free to do that.
But they are not free
to force all of us
to subsidize their activism.
And that's what they were doing.
They have their own government,
or they did have their
own government right here.
They're exempt from laws,
they get massive tax breaks.
And so, you know,
if their company is
committed to that view
of what's appropriate
for children and
parents as the state,
we just can't have a
partnership with that.
And so we're out and
that's why we took action
to dissolve their
own government.
(cheering)
- So, so I know we could do,
we could do politics all
day long and I do politics
for a living and these
guys, they're into politics,
but there's something
else going on here I think
that you exemplify which is
just one man against the system.
That you just said no.
And I wanna know just
on a personal level,
not at a political level,
where do you think that
came from within you?
Was that something
that you always had?
I mean when the Covid
stuff was happening
and everybody else locked down,
everybody else followed Fauci.
Every, you said no.
I mean that's all,
you just said no.
And I wanna know where did that
really come from within you?
- Well look, I think that
there are people that,
that get involved in
elected office who are there
to be able to enjoy the
accoutrements of office,
to be able to have a title.
And then there are
people that get in
because they actually
wanna do something
and they also wanna
make a difference.
So I'm the latter.
And when I became governor,
I remember going into the
office for the first time
sitting in the chair and
I said you know what?
I don't know what SOB's
gonna end up succeeding me
in eight years, but
I can tell you this,
there ain't gonna be any meat
left on the bone for them
'cause I'm gonna take on
issues, I'm gonna be on offense.
I'm not just gonna sit back.
I'm gonna make sure that we're
really making a difference,
but I would do it based on
what I thought was right.
And I have not taken a poll
since I've been governor.
I'm not trying to
react to whatever.
Some, you know, random
burst of opinion.
My view is is when you lead,
if you set out the vision
and you execute the vision
and you do well, people
will follow that.
And that's what they wanna see.
And so that was
just my philosophy.
And so when it came
for like Covid,
you know I remember like you
know just getting hammered
by corporate press and
they politicized it.
They wanted to use
it to take out Trump.
They wanted to use it to
take out people like me.
And that's just what they do.
But you know my view was okay,
if by me protecting the jobs
of all the people I represent,
ends up putting my own job
in jeopardy then so be it.
Let the chips fall
where they may.
I wasn't worried about politics
and I would totally be willing
to because look I have,
there's great, there's a lot
of opportunities in life.
It isn't like I have to do this.
And so if it didn't
work out for me,
I would've been totally
great being able to look
in the mirror and
say you know what,
I did what I thought was right
to benefit the
people I represent.
I think when you get in
situations where some of these
politicians, you know they
get paralyzed by polls
and consultants and everything,
and then they don't
do what they think
in their guts right because
they're worried about blow back.
They're worried about the media.
They're worried about
political consequences.
Well then guess what happens?
You end up not succeeding
most of the time anyways,
then you end up looking
in the mirror like man,
I just wish I would've
followed what I believed in.
And so you know, no regrets,
you gotta do what
you think is right.
And in this case with Florida I,
you know with Covid I actually
consumed the data myself.
I didn't just, I
wasn't just, you know,
saying if Fauci says something,
then you got a genuflect.
What are they
getting at the data?
And the fact is Fauci was wrong
about a lot of this stuff.
Okay.
(cheering)
We were the first big state
to guarantee every parent
the ability to send their
kid to school in person,
way back in 2020, right?
Fauci opposed us
having kids in school.
He opposed what we were doing
when we had businesses open
and protecting people's jobs
and were having these events.
He opposed us every
step of the way.
And so that wasn't based on
data because the schooling
was obvious that you needed
to have the kids in school.
It was based more on ideology
and it was more based on
all these other things.
So we were right to have
to stand up to Fauci.
- We'll respect your free
speech if you respect ours,
but you gotta do it outside.
You gotta do it outside.
- So at the end of the day
that's just my philosophy.
And I would just,
I think that you gotta do
what you think is right.
I tend to, you know if
there's a choice between
going against the machine
and siding with the folks
I'm gonna side with the folks.
And here's the thing, I think,
that I think people get it
more than they ever have.
They understand you look at
some of these elite bureaucrats
like Fauci, you look at the
corporate media, big tech,
the emperor has no clothes.
These are discredited
elites in our country
and they don't have your
best interest at heart.
They don't have this state's
Sometimes though it
doesn't feel like you know
your voice can be heard because
so much of it is dominated
by this one viewpoint.
But when you stand up and
you stand in that fire
and you fight back
for people, man,
they will have your back.
They will support you
and that's what we've shown
in the state of Florida.
(cheering)
See.
(applause)
- He doesn't like polls, but
standing ovations ain't bad.
You know, those are pretty good.
I got an idea.
So, you know if you
weren't a politician,
well, how about this maybe?
And you guys could
chime in on this.
We don't have to put the
governor on the spot,
but maybe like, you know you
crush it in this next election
here in Florida.
Let's do maybe eight
years in the White House.
And then you become
CEO of Disney.
How does that sound?
(cheering)
- You know who
knows what happens?
You never know in life so.
- Alright so, so let's talk
about some of the other stuff
that you're doing,
'cause you really are doing
stuff here that is not happening
in the rest of the country.
You just signed this fatherhood
bill last month here.
This is just another
issue that you took on
that seemingly we
need to talk about,
we don't talk about honestly
and you chose to fight it.
So tell me a little
bit about that.
- Yeah I mean I think that if
you look at what's going on
in our, in our society.
(yelling)
Did they have to at
least pay to get in here?
- Oh they had to pay.
- Good, good, good.
(cheering)
I mean like, look, I get
people have their shtick.
I get people, you know do
things a little bit different
on that side than we would.
But honestly it's
so ineffective.
Nobody, all you do is
tick people off when you,
you try to interrupt
these events.
So keep doing it, you're just
gonna help us in the long run.
But.
- And you live in
Florida, Florida, people.
- But you know
the fatherhood is,
is interesting
because if you look at
all the different problems
society could deal with
a huge number of them are
rooted in kids growing up
without having a
father in the home
and so I started getting
involved in this when I was,
my first year as governor,
we're doing the budget.
There was some money for a
group called All Pro Dads
and it was founded
by former Bucks
and Colt's head coach Tony
Dungy who's a great guy.
And Tony and you know look,
I just signed next
year's budget.
I vetoed a world, Florida
record $3.1 billion.
Before I became governor the
record was like $800 million.
And so we're, we're very
tough and I mean we will veto
and so you can veto
individual items.
And so he called me just to
kind of like make the pitch
and you know I'm like
honestly, I trust you.
I know you're gonna, your
heart's in the right place.
And I know this is important.
So we started getting involved.
We'd work with private groups,
we'd work with our state
agencies and then this year
kind of a more
comprehensive thing.
But if you talk to coach Dungy
and he was at the bill signing.
When he said when he
became Tampa Bay head coach
he went to minister at some
of the prisons and he looked
and he said you know,
I noticed that it wasn't
because of poverty, race,
all these other things.
The reason these people were
in prison was because they did
not have a father
figure in the home.
And if you could address that,
you would have so much better
luck in society overall.
And so that's what
we're trying to do.
And part of it is
resources, education.
Part of it though is
sending a message to men,
meet your responsibilities.
You have a responsibility.
And I can tell you,
you know one of the
reasons I ran for governor,
I was a member of
Congress for a few terms.
And I first got elected.
It was just my wife and me.
Second election it was
just my wife and me.
Well then after the
third election, 2016,
we had our first child,
our daughter Madison.
And so I'm in DC
thinking to myself,
you travel back and forth.
I'm like, why am I up here?
You know, I really
want to be back home.
And so as with
governor, you know,
we see him every day.
We're able to be present
and I'm very busy.
I'm much busier in this job
than a Congressman would be.
But because we're all
in the same state,
all in the, you know obviously
living in Tallahassee now,
you're able to do it.
So my wife and I put a
lot of emphasis on that
but particularly me.
They're, they're just, you know,
my wife does some great things
that I don't do as good in,
but I offer just something
else in terms of,
in terms of for the
kids to look up to.
So I think it's essential.
And I've said if we
could snap our fingers,
every kid grows up
in America with a,
with a good father in the home,
we would not be talking about
a lot of these other problems,
no way.
(applause)
- So as a new Floridian one of
the things that's constantly
on my mind is what can
I do for this state?
And I really mean that, what
can I do for this state that I,
I feel like a refugee.
I am a refugee.
It, I genuinely feel like
I came from another country
and thank God you guys
speak English here.
That's basically, that's
basically where I'm at.
But so what do we do, what
do we do to defend Florida?
Because the more that
Florida does it right.
The more that the machine,
whether that's the media
or the political machine,
or just the elite machine,
whatever you wanna call it,
the more it is going
to stare down you,
stare down these folks.
What do we do to just
keep this state right?
- Well, I think it's
a great question.
And before I answer it
just let me say this
about California.
So first time.
- You gotta put money in the
jar man, that's the deal.
- So Covid hits.
First time I went to
California since Covid
was June of 2021.
So over a year into
Covid but you know
they still had mandates.
They had, it was
not like Florida.
So I, so I'm out there doing
stuff like fundraising,
all this stuff.
And I told myself, I'm like
look, I'm not wearing a mask.
I'm gonna do my thing.
So you put me wherever
you wanna put me,
but just understand.
I don't want any confrontation
or anything but this is,
I'm gonna live like
I live in Florida.
So I get there.
First day I'm
there, I'm waiting.
The cars are coming
to pick me up.
I'm on the curb.
These two guys in masks
come scurrying over to me.
I'm like oh God, here we go.
One guy gets right in front
of me, pulls down his mask,
looks me right in
the eye and says,
I wish you were our governor.
Put on the mask and left.
So you never know.
(cheering)
And so it was interesting.
But what I would say is
when you're looking at.
Big time fail buddy,
big time fail.
(jeering)
You know part of what
we're doing I think now is
we've been able to
create so much momentum
that like 2018 election,
very close call for the state
of Florida when I got elected.
'Cause if I had not gotten
elected, many of you,
none of you who moved
here would've moved here.
And some of you that lived here
probably would've moved
away, just the truth.
But when I got elected
we had almost 300,000
more registered
Democrats in the state
of Florida than Republicans.
And we never had
had more registered
Republicans in Florida
prior to me becoming governor.
Well, negative 300,000
November of 2018,
June 1st, 2022, we have 150,000
more registered Republicans.
Now.
(cheering)
so I think that that is
telling us that we have
an opportunity to really
solidify the direction
that the state's
going this November.
And so I would say, you know
my election very important
and we just need
a massive turnout
and I think we can get it.
You know people will come
up to me who you can tell
are not super political
and they'll thank me
for saving their job.
They'll thank me for saving
their kids' education.
They'll thank me for
saving their business
and they wanna be helpful.
So we have an
opportunity to do that.
And I think that that's
absolutely critical,
but I also think, you know
we've got a lot of great people
that have moved in here.
I mean you look at like,
you know down in Miami.
You know, Miami is like this.
I mean, first of all it's never
boomed the way it's booming,
but it's moving right.
And there aren't very
many urban environments
in this country that
are really moving right.
And you know, part of it is
the, is the demographics.
I mean, you know, you look at
like our Hispanic communities,
they are conservative and
they wanna make sure that this
country doesn't
repeat the mistakes of
these other countries
in Latin America, where you
had Marxism take over Cuba,
Venezuela, all
these other places.
And so I think particularly
with you guys in south Florida,
because it used to be south
Florida would be like huge blue.
You know, then you'd
have pockets of blue,
Orlando, Gainesville, whatever.
And the rest would
either be really red
or maybe kind of purple.
And now south Florida is
becoming much more conservative.
And I think that that's
largely, I think it's too,
I do think it's a
result of the migration.
And I think it's a reaction
against Brandon's policies,
which let's be honest, have
not been terribly successful.
You know when I did
the budget thing today,
we were at the Villages and
I, and I just point out.
There's news reports,
recent news reports.
He's so frustrated that
his approval ratings
are in the toilet and he's
lashing out at his staff
blaming this, blaming that.
And I'm just thinking to myself,
you have a situation where,
you know you came in.
And oh by the way, for,
for any more of those
people that are out here,
we're not gonna
let them take away
your constitutional rights.
(cheering)
Not gonna happen.
[Crowd] USA, USA, USA,
USA, USA, USA, USA.
- But you have, so but
Brandon he's lashing out,
blaming other people.
And I'm just thinking
to myself man,
you wanna know why your approval
ratings are in the toilet
look in the mirror, your
policies are failing.
People don't wanna pay
$4.75 a gallon for gas
and it is gonna be
over $5 very soon.
They don't wanna war against
domestic American energy.
You know for some
reason with Biden,
if you beg Maduro for oil,
that's somehow not
global warming,
but if we produce our own,
then it's global warming.
Give me a break, what a farce.
And so he's creating a lot of
these problems and here's the,
I mean I'd say between
Brandon and Covid,
I think there's a lot of
voters out there who are,
who have reevaluated maybe
some of how they voted.
Some people just vote
one way or another.
Maybe their parents
were Republicans.
So they were
Democrats or whatever.
Now people are starting
to look, wait a minute.
Do I wanna be with a party
if this guy's the leader?
Do I want to be a part of a
party that says I don't have
a right to earn a living
unless I take boosters
every time Fauci tells me to?
Do I wanna be a part, do I
want to be a part of a party
that doesn't believe
we should have control
over our territory
and our borders?
Like you see what's going
on in the Southern border.
And I think a lot of people
are saying, you know what,
that's not for me.
So it gives us an
opportunity I think to build
a stronger movement here.
And I think the Southern Florida
is gonna be absolutely huge
to the future of this state.
(applause)
- Well first I just
wanna say that I love
that you keep
calling him Brandon,
because I think it's possible
he thinks his name is Brandon.
So that's pretty beautiful.
Also I wasn't gonna
do this at the end.
We only have one more,
time for one more question,
but I wanted to give you a
let's go Brandon t-shirt.
It seems that he
should put it on right
now and rip it off
Hulk Hogan style.
(applause)
Alright, one more for you.
Sort of on that bravery thing
that we talked about before
and where that comes
from within you
and all of these people
that are out here.
And as we watch
this thing happen
and watch the media come after
you and all of that stuff,
what else can they do to fight?
What else can they do?
What can empower them to
just be part of this thing
and keep this state right,
keep this country
right and go on?
- Well one of the things,
the points I'll make,
and obviously I mention
Biden's failures a lot
and deservedly so,
but here's the thing.
I could deal with that if
in exchange I could have
a conservative majority
on every school board
in America for example.
What you can do at the local
level to really be involved
in your community, particularly
with these schools.
Because I think that we've
led a lot at the state level,
you know, making sure that
that obviously the young kids,
you know aren't having
the sexuality involved
and the gender ideology.
Also making sure that we
don't have things like
critical race theory
and all these ideologies
and that's important.
But really it's the parents
and the people that are running
for school board and
all these other things.
And so, yes I obviously
made a plug for my election.
I think it's very important,
but I think these
school board elections
have more importance
than ever before.
You guys can make a huge
difference in your community
and you know the
moms have done great
and the parents are
energized like never before.
And they should be really
leading the effort,
but you know what?
You don't even have to have
kids in the school system
to be concerned about what's
going on with education.
Because if you, if we do our
job right, and we're doing,
you know, good solid education.
I think you need to have things
like we've pushed in
Florida, American civics,
understanding the constitution,
understanding all those things.
If we're providing a solid
foundation for education
rather than having
these systems become
centers of indoctrination,
you are gonna be,
we are gonna be so much
better off as a state
than a lot of
these other places.
And so I would just say,
get involved in some
of these local races,
get involved in some of
these local organizations,
because you really
can move the needle.
I mean the enemy really in
some respects, yes, the left,
but also just being apathetic
because when we're apathetic,
then the left is able
to capitalize off that.
So I think those days are over.
I think we realize that, you
know we're in a fight to ensure
the survival of liberty
and opportunity for not
only ourselves, our kids,
but even generations yet unborn.
And so you know now's the time
to saddle up and get it done.
And so I would love to
see, yes, big red wave.
People will focus on my race,
some of these other races,
but I would love to see a
big red wave sweep these
school board races
across the state.
That'll make a huge difference.
(applause)
- Well Governor, I wanna
thank you for taking the time
to join us here tonight.
Truly by you doing the right
thing, my life is better.
Everyone in this audience,
their lives are better.
(cheering)
And on that note ladies and
gentlemen make some noise
for Governor Ron
DeSantis everybody.
Governor Ron DeSantis.
♪ Sweet Florida ♪
♪ My governor is red,
white, and blue ♪
♪ Oh down in sweet Florida ♪
♪ He's shooting us straight,
telling us the truth ♪
♪ Yeah that's right ♪
Ladies and gentlemen I have
been on tour for two months.
We thought it was right
to end it in Orlando
with the Governor.
You guys have been
absolutely awesome.
I am telling you I am, I am
truly the proudest new Floridian
and I thank you
for doing it right.
I thank you for watching.
I thank you for supporting me.
I thank you for coming out
and fighting for freedom
and laughing at those freaks.
And on that note everybody,
thank you very much.
You guys are awesome.
Let's go Brandon.
Let's keep Florida
Florida everybody.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling
check out our
politics playlists.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety
of topics watch our
full episode playlists
all right over here.
And to get notified of
all future videos be sure
to subscribe and click
the notification bell.